I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello. Hi, lady. How are you? I'm very excited. Well, I'm excited. Before we get to it, you're having a super cute hair day. Oh my gosh, lady. I got my hair cut and I got it colored. And so it's like very fresh. You look salsa and fresh. Thank you. Well, it's good timing too because we have a special guest today. We do. You guys. You gave me a compliment.
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有当时身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。你好。嗨，女士。你好吗？我非常兴奋。好吧，我很兴奋。在我们开始之前，你今天的发型超级可爱。哦，天哪，女士。我剪了头发，还染了。所以看起来非常清新。你看起来神采奕奕、清新动人。谢谢。嗯，这也是个好时机，因为我们今天有一位特别嘉宾。我们确实有。你们大家。你夸了我。
Can I give you a compliment? Yeah. I love your sweater. I said it when you walked in and you said it was... It's like six years old. It's so cute. Because I can't take a compliment. You're like, I like your sweater. And I was like, it's really old. Well, the point is we look really stinking cute today. And it's a good thing because someone's here. Yeah. We juged up because we have a guest here today is Will Ferrell. Otherwise known as D'Angelo Vickers. We thought we would do a little, I don't know, summary of Will Ferrell, but come on. You guys all know him. He was on Saturday Night Live for so many years. He was amazing. He got an Emmy nomination for being on SNL. You know, he's also been
我能夸夸你吗？可以。我很喜欢你的毛衣。你一走进来我就这么说了，你说那是……这大概是六年前的了。太可爱了。因为我不太会接受赞美。你会说，我喜欢你的毛衣。然后我就说，这真的很旧。好吧，重点是我们今天看起来超级无敌可爱。而且这很好，因为有人来了。对。我们盛装打扮了一番，因为我们今天迎来了嘉宾——威尔·费瑞尔。也就是大家熟知的迪安杰洛·维克斯。我们本想对威尔·费瑞尔做一个小小的，我不知道，总结，但是拜托。你们大家都认识他。他在《周六夜现场》呆了那么多年。他太棒了。他因为在SNL的表现获得了艾美奖提名。你知道，他还参演过
in a gazillion movies. I was in a movie with him, Blades of Glory. He's also been in Elf, Anchorman, Kicking and Screaming, Teledagonites, Semi-Pro, Step Brothers. And he received Golden Globe nominations for his roles in the producers and stranger than fiction and for producing vice. Also, he has done so many voiceovers. If you guys like the Lego movies like my kids, then you know he was Lord Business and he was hilarious. He might be the funniest person on the planet, Jenna. He might be one of the funniest people I've ever met. This is true. Mm-hmm. We got to spend over an hour chatting with him. We talked about his time in the office, but we also just talked about life and all kinds of things. All kinds of
无数的电影。我和他一起演过一部电影，《冰刀双人组》。他还演过《精灵总动员》、《王牌播音员》、《冰球坏小子》、《塔拉迪加之夜》、《半职业选手》、《非亲兄弟》，并且凭借在《制片人》和《笔下求生》中的角色以及担任《副总统》的制片人获得了金球奖提名。此外，他还做过很多配音。如果你和我的孩子一样喜欢乐高电影，那么你就会知道他是雷克斯总统，而且他搞笑极了。他可能是地球上最搞笑的人，珍娜。他可能是我见过的最搞笑的人之一。千真万确。嗯哼。我们和他聊了一个多小时。我们聊了他在《办公室》的那段时光，但也聊了生活和各种各样的事情。各种各样
things. It was really fun. He's just, oh my gosh, he's everything I remembered him to be when we worked with him. So nice. Mm-hmm. So funny. But just a charming human to be around. Well, before we get to that interview, we do have a little announcement. Little Office Lady's business. Yeah. We are taking the next two weeks off. That's right. We have our kid's spring break and I'm doing a movie. Jump roll, Jenna's doing a movie. Yes, I am doing the Mean Girls Movie Musical for Paramount Plus written by Tina Fey. I can't wait to see it. It's going to be so great. You said Tim Meadows is back. Yes, Tim Meadows is in it. And you know, I did Walk Hard with Tim Meadows, so I'm so excited. And he was on The Office.
的事情。真的很有趣。他简直是，哦天哪，他就是我当年合作时记忆中的那个样子。人超好。嗯哼。超搞笑。而且是个极具魅力的交往对象。好了，在进入那段采访之前，我们有一个小公告。办公室女郎的小广播。对。我们接下来两周要休息。没错。我们要陪孩子过春季假期，而且我要拍一部电影。敲黑板，珍娜要拍电影了。是的，我要为派拉蒙+出演由蒂娜·菲编剧的《贱女孩》音乐电影。我等不及要看了。一定超级棒。你说蒂姆·梅多斯回归了？对，蒂姆·梅多斯参演了。而且你知道的，我和蒂姆·梅多斯合作过《疯狂原始人》（注：应为《永不退缩》），所以我太兴奋了。而且他上过《办公室》。
We love him. I play Ms. Herron. Mm-hmm. I play Katie's mom. I have shot one day on the movie so far, but now I have to go back to do the bulk of my work over these next couple of weeks. I mean, just based on the one day I've done so far, I could not be more excited. So sorry, guys, but we have to hit pause on the podcast, but we'll be back in two weeks. Two weeks. All right. We're going to take a break. And then we'll be back with Will Ferrell. Woo-hoo! Yay! Welcome, Will Ferrell. Yay, Will's here. I love the theme song. Thank you. Wait, you're best friends. Yes. Did that, was that pre-the show or during the show? During the show.
我们都很喜欢他。我饰演赫伦女士。嗯哼。我饰演凯蒂的妈妈。到目前为止我在这部电影里只拍了一天，但我接下来几周得回去完成大部分工作。我是说，仅凭我目前拍的那一天来看，我简直兴奋得无以复加。所以很抱歉，伙计们，我们要暂停播客两周，但我们两周后会回来。两周后。好吧。我们要休息一下。然后我们将带着威尔·费瑞尔回归。呜呼！耶！欢迎威尔·费瑞尔。耶，威尔来啦。我喜欢这个主题曲。谢谢。等等，你们是好朋友。是的。那是，那是节目之前还是节目期间？节目期间。
You guys became friends on the show. Yes. Yes. Wow. Mm-hmm. Became besties. And maybe one of, if not the greatest takeaway of doing the show in a weird way, right? 100%. That's what Steve said. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Do you have a best friend, Will? From The Office. Sure. Sure. Did I made? Because we're only, that's the only contact. It's a late office specific. In those four episodes. Do not have. Who is your best friend from those four episodes? You can say Steve. You knew him before. Yeah. I guess I'll say Steve. Okay. Yeah. Since I knew him before. Okay. Yeah. Not Creed. You and Creed aren't hanging out. I didn't talk to Creed that much. No. I didn't talk to any. It was an interesting time. Oh. Oh.
你们是在节目里认识并成为朋友的。是的。是的。哇。嗯哼。成了闺蜜。而且也许是，如果不是最棒的话，也是制作这个节目带来的最棒的收获之一，从某种奇怪的角度来说，对吧？百分之百。史蒂夫也是这么说的。对。对。对。你有好朋友吗，威尔？从《办公室》里。当然。当然。我有结交吗？因为我们只有，那是唯一的接触。那是具体的《办公室》经历。在那四集里。没有。谁是你在这四集里的好朋友？你可以说是史蒂夫。你之前就认识他。对。我想我会说是史蒂夫。好吧。对。既然我之前就认识他。好吧。对。不是克里德。你和克里德可没一起闲逛。我和克里德没怎么说过话。没有。我谁也没怎么说。那是一段有趣的时光。哦。哦。
This sounds like it's going to be a hard hitting. It was an interesting time. Well, anyway. We'll get there. I bet we have some questions that crack that open. Yeah. Okay. Best friend in real life. Best friend in real life. You can say their first name only if you don't want to alienate all the other friends. I'm going to say the initial Jay. Jay's been there for you through thick and thin. Thick and thin. All right. Well, here we go. In preparing for this interview, Jen and I were Googling. We were looking you up on the internet. Okay. I stumbled across something on your Wikipedia page that really cracked me up. I have to read it to you. Let's see if it holds muster. Right. Okay. They list all the types of acting
听起来这会是一个犀利的问题。那是一段有趣的时光。好吧，无论如何。我们会聊到的。我敢说我们有些问题能打破这个局面。好吧。现实生活中的好朋友。现实生活中的好朋友。如果你不想疏远其他所有朋友，你只能说出他们的名字首字母。我要说字母J。J一直在你身边，无论顺境还是逆境。无论顺境逆境。好吧。那么，我们开始吧。在准备这次采访时，珍娜和我在谷歌上搜索了你。我们在网上查了你。好的。我在你的维基百科页面上偶然发现了一些真正让我大笑的内容。我得读给你听听。看看它经不经得起推敲。对。好吧。上面列出了所有类型的表演
genres that you are featured in. Okay. Ready? Here are the genres. Improvisational comedy, sketch comedy, physical comedy, character comedy, cringe comedy, political satire, surreal humor, anti-humor, and deadpan. Wow. Does that like... Those are all the things. That's the whole spectrum you can do. In comedy in a weird way. I mean... I love cringe. Cringe comedy. And that I'm in anti-comedy. Yes. I've... That's the one I didn't understand. What is anti-humor? I mean, is that not drama? It's a type of humor. I guess. Or is it something that's actually really funny that that person thought was not funny and described it as anti-comedy? I don't know. I don't know. I couldn't tell if they were...
你所涉及的流派。好的。准备好了吗？流派如下。即兴喜剧、小品喜剧、形体喜剧、性格喜剧、尴尬喜剧、政治讽刺、超现实幽默、反幽默和死板幽默（黑色幽默）。哇。这像吗……这些就是所有的东西。这就是你能做的整个范围。在某种奇怪的喜剧中。我是说……我喜欢尴尬。尴尬喜剧。而我处于反喜剧中。是的。我……那是唯一我没搞懂的。什么是反幽默？我是说，那难道不是正剧吗？这是一种幽默。我猜。或者它是某种其实真的很好笑，但那个人觉得不好笑并把它描述为反喜剧的东西？我不知道。我不知道。我看不出他们是不是在……
Things that go over people. I've never heard that... Yeah. I couldn't tell if they were praising you or throwing shit at you. I love that it's on my Wikipedia page, which I obviously don't curate at all. But I'm going to now start telling people that's my specialty, anti-comedy. Anti-humor. Look on Wikipedia. Some people think it's... It's a real thing. No, no, no. It's anti-comedy. Anti-humor. This is anti-humor. Anti-humor. Will, before we get started, I did want to introduce myself to you. Jenna Fisher. Right. We did Blades of Glory together. We did The Office. Yes. This is a little inside joke
那些让人摸不着头脑的东西。我从来没听过那个……对。我看不出他们是在赞美你还是在朝你泼脏水。我喜欢它出现在我的维基百科页面上，我显然一点也没有去维护它。但从现在开始，我要告诉别人那是我的专长，反喜剧。反幽默。去维基百科上看看。有些人认为它是……这是一件真事。不，不，不。这是反喜剧。反幽默。这就是反喜剧。反幽默。威尔，在我们开始之前，我确实想向你作个自我介绍。珍娜·费舍。没错。我们一起合作过《冰刀双人组》。我们一起演过《办公室》。是的。这是一个小小的内部笑话
because I told a story on the podcast. I'm sure you don't remember, but early on in knowing you, every time I would run into you after we did Blades of Glory, I would say, Will, hey, Jenna Fisher, we did Blades of Glory. And at one event, you finally... You took me by the hand. You said, Jenna, I know who you are. I do... You don't need to introduce me every time. I was like, okay, well, you've worked with so many people. You've done so many things. I just thought maybe I would help you recall me if needed. It was really a sweet moment. You're like, you don't ever have to do this. So I told her when you showed up today, I was like, you have to introduce yourself again.
因为我在播客里讲过一个故事。我确信你不记得了，但在认识你的早期，每次我们在拍完《冰刀双人组》后碰面，我都会说，威尔，嘿，我是珍娜·费舍，我们一起拍过《冰刀双人组》。在一次活动中，你终于……你拉着我的手。你说，珍娜，我知道你是谁。我……你不需要每次都自我介绍。当时我就想，好吧，你和那么多人合作过。你做过那么多事情。我只是觉得也许如果需要的话，我可以帮你回忆起我。那真是一个温馨的时刻。你说，你根本不用这么做。所以我今天在你出现时告诉她，我说，你必须再次自我介绍。
Was there something else we worked on, too? Or were those the two main things? You know, it's so funny. I felt like there was. I felt like there was, too. But in Googling us, I couldn't find it. What else have we done? I thought there was something before Blades. Were you in Step Brothers? No. But I was in that movie with Will Arnett and Will Forte, the brother Solomon. Oh, the brother Solomon. I wasn't in that. But you weren't in that. No. I know. I went through my list of things. They weren't looking for anti-humor. No. I guess not. No. So you didn't get
难道我们还有合作过别的吗？还是说那是主要的两个？你知道，太搞笑了吧。我觉得好像还有。我也觉得好像有。但在谷歌搜索我们时，我找不到。我们还做过什么？我以为在《冰刀》之前还有别的。你演过《非亲兄弟》吗？没有。但我演过那部电影，和威尔·阿奈特还有威尔·福特，叫《所罗门兄弟》。哦，《所罗门兄弟》。我没演那个。但你没演那个。没有。我知道。我浏览了我的作品清单。他们不是在寻找反喜剧。没有。我想不是吧。没有。所以你没
to job. The phone didn't ring. Not for that one. Not for that one. No. Here is a question we ask all of our guests. How did you get your job on the office? I got my job on the office. I had called up my peeps, my representation. No. I just thrown it out that I knew it was Steve's last year. And I just said, God, I would love to do something in that last season. I was thinking it'd be just a cameo or whatever. Right. It was up for anything. And my agent called me back and said, oh, yeah, they're thrilled. In fact, they want to know, Greg was like,
去面试。电话没响。那个没有。那个没有。没有。这里有一个我们问所有嘉宾的问题。你是怎么得到《办公室》里的工作的？我得到了《办公室》的工作。我给我的密友们打了电话，也就是我的经纪团队。不。我只是随口一提，我知道那是史蒂夫的最后一年。我只是说，天哪，我真想在那最后一季里做点什么。我以为只是客串一下什么的。对。我什么都行。我的经纪人回电话说，哦，是的，他们很高兴。事实上，他们想知道，格雷格的意思是
would you actually want to do a whole arc, like four shows? And I thought, yeah, why not? That'd be great. But that's what I was alluding to when I didn't talk to many people on the set because those last shows were emotionally charged. And you guys were all having a moment. And I'm like, what am I doing here? I shouldn't be here. I was always like, oh my God, here's another read through, everyone's going to cry. And I was like, I was invited to the party and I wasn't, someone realized way after the fact, Will shouldn't be here. And while I had a great time and it was so fun to be a part of your guy's thing, there was a big part of it. I just really felt like an outsider to no one's fault. But it was like, as you
你真的愿意演整整一个故事线，比如四集吗？我想，嗯，为什么不呢？那太棒了。但这正是我之前暗指的，为什么我没有跟片场的很多人说话，因为最后这几集充满了情绪。你们大家都在经历某种情绪时刻。而我在想，我在这里干什么？我不应该在这里。我总是觉得，天哪，又是一次剧本围读，每个人都要哭了。然后我就想，我是被邀请参加派对的，但后来有人很久之后才意识到，威尔根本不该在这里。虽然我度过了一段美好的时光，能成为你们大家的事情的一部分真的很有趣，但其中很大一部分，我真的觉得自己像个局外人，虽然没人犯错。但就像你们
guys know, this end of an era. We were all just in our feelings. Oh yeah. And you should have been. So that's where I was like, I didn't talk to a lot of people because I didn't feel like. You were like, I'm just going to stay out of the way. I'm just going to stay out of the way. Because you guys are all having private moments. And it was almost, you know, it was like, sign my yearbook, end of year, make sure. So I was such a distinct memory when we were doing Michael's Last Dundies. Yes. My character gets the word for kind of a bitch. And I had to go up there. And while we were doing the scene, they sort of, we had a moment where we took a lighting break or something. And
所知道的，这是一个时代的终结。我们都沉浸在情绪中。哦，是的。你们本该如此。所以这就是为什么我当时说，我没有和很多人说话，因为我觉得我……你会觉得，我还是别碍事了。我还是别碍事了。因为你们大家都在经历私人时刻。而且几乎，你知道，就像是，在我的毕业纪念册上签名吧，学年结束了，确保……所以我有一个非常深刻的记忆，当时我们在拍迈克尔的告别派对。是的。我的角色得到了一个有点像荡妇的词。我不得不走上去。当我们在拍那个场景时，他们稍微，我们有个间隙暂停去调整灯光什么的，然后
I was standing next to you. And I just said to you, how's it going? And you said, you said, oh, it's great. It's great. I kind of feel like I'm doing comedy bits at a funeral. Sometimes. Yeah. Yeah. But I'll never forget. I was like, oh, this is going to be so hard. It's going to be so hard to come in and try to be like the new funny guy. And we're all just like, yeah, we had a really fun fan question. This question from Joanna asked, did anyone advise you not to take this role? Oh, Joanna. No, no one. But I, that makes me laugh. The image of a lot of people calling me going, be careful. Don't do it. Don't do it. Hey, you might want to. Can we talk? You might want to. Although you might be great at it
我站在你旁边。我只是对你说了句，最近怎么样？然后你说，你说，哦，挺好的。挺好的。我感觉自己就像在葬礼上讲单口喜剧。有时是这样。对。对。但我永远不会忘记。当时我就想，哦，这会很难。作为一个新人想进来当那个搞笑的人会很难。而我们大家都觉得，是的，我们有一个非常有趣的粉丝提问。乔安娜的这个问题问的是，有没有人建议你不要接演这个角色？哦，乔安娜。没有，没有人。但是，这让我大笑。脑补一下很多人打电话给我说，小心点。别去。别去。嘿，你可能想要……我们能谈谈吗？你可能想要……虽然你可能很擅长
because there might be some anti humor. No, no one, no one advised me not to take the role, which, you know, previously to what we were talking about, it was so fun to be there too. You know, it was great to watch you guys all work and be a part of that as well. But, but it was really surreal. Yeah. From our perspective, you folded into the show so naturally. Oh, good. Like so easily. And you were there that one episode after Steve had left. Yes. You stayed for one more. Yeah. And oh my gosh, we were so happy to have you there. Just as a little bit of a bridge. Yeah. Yeah. And your energy is similar to Steve's. You guys are both so nice. Right. And just your kindness and your humor. We
因为可能会有一些反幽默。不，没有人，没有人建议我不要接演这个角色，你知道，正如我们之前所说，能在那里也非常有趣。你知道，看着你们大家工作并成为其中一部分的感觉真的很棒，但是，但是这真的太超现实了。是的。从我们的角度来看，你非常自然地融入了节目中。哦，太好了。就像非常轻松一样。而且你在史蒂夫离开后又多待了一集。是的。你多待了一场。是的。哦天哪，我们太高兴你能在那儿了。就好像是一个小小的桥梁。对。对。而且你的能量和史蒂夫很像。你们两个人都那么好。对。仅仅是你们的善良和幽默。我们
were like, okay, good. But singing the rent song in the, you know, in Steve losing it, I was like, if there was a camera on me, it'd be like, oh, he's not acting. Oh, he's. That deer in headlights is real. I was like, oh my God. Okay. Yeah. Right. Of course. Oh, now I get the scene. But that was really, that was so sweet and powerful and. Yeah. And we were all crying. We were all looking at you because you were standing in the front of the room with Steve and we were all looking at you crying. I am just now in this moment. Yeah. Like putting myself in your shoes and imagining what it must have been like for you to stand there and Steve is crying next to you. Yes. We're all crying and you're just
当时就想，哦，太好了。但是在里面唱着《吉屋出租》的歌，你知道的，在史蒂夫失控的时候，我就想，如果当时有台摄像机对着我，就会觉得，哦，他不是在演戏。哦，他……那副不知所措的样子是真的。当时我就想，哦天哪。好的。对。没错。哦，我现在明白这个场景了。但那真的很温馨，很有感染力，而且。是的。而且我们都在哭。我们都在看着你，因为你和史蒂夫一起站在房间的最前面，我们都在看着你哭。我直到现在这一刻。是的。才把自己代入你的处境，想象一下当时你站在那里，史蒂夫在你身边哭泣，那种感觉会是什么样。是的。我们都在哭，而你却
like, hey. And then as D'Angelo Vickers who has no emotional attachment, then the more takes we did, then it started getting to me too. Right. And you're like, D'Angelo can't cry here. D'Angelo can't cry here. He doesn't have anything invested. Here's another fan question. Okay. This is from Shell F. Had you watched the show before you came on? Yes. I had watched the show many a time and yeah, I was a fan like everyone else and just loved, you know, all the stuff everyone was doing and all the writing and the cast and just as you guys know, kind of a perfect storm of all those things put together, which is why the combination of that and knowing Steve, but all of those things were the reason why
只是，嘿。然后作为没有任何情感纠葛的迪安杰洛·维克斯，随着我们拍的条数越来越多，我也开始被感染了。对。然后你会想，迪安杰洛在这里不能哭。迪安杰洛在这里不能哭。他没有任何情感投入。这里还有另一个粉丝提问。好的。这是来自谢尔·F的问题。你来之前看过这个节目吗？看过。我看过这个节目很多次，是的，我和其他人一样是个粉丝，只是很喜欢，你知道，大家在做的所有事情以及所有的剧本和演员，正如你们所知道的，所有这些因素完美结合的产物，这就是为什么结合了这一点以及认识史蒂夫，但所有这些因素都是原因
I called up. I was like, gosh, would they, would they fit me in? And you guys did. And you got to go play with one of your best friends. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, exactly. And that was so fun to revisiting the episodes. I had totally forgotten that first. The first meeting between Michael and D'Angelo? Where we're at the bar and calling each other and we don't realize it. And it was like I was watching them all for the first time. It was just so fun to see how well constructed that was. And just, yeah, so stupid. Right? Yeah. Okay, this is actually a great time for me to share this with you. I saw online
我打了电话。当时我就想，天哪，他们会，他们会把我塞进去吗？而你们真的这么做了。而且你还能去和你的一个好朋友一起玩。对，没错。是的，没错。而且重新看这些那一集真的很搞笑。我完全忘了第一场。迈克尔和迪安杰洛的第一次会面？我们在酒吧里互相打电话却没意识到。这就像我是第一次看所有这些一样。看到它构建得如此精妙，真的是太有趣了。而且，是的，太愚蠢了。对吧？是的。好吧，其实现在是和我分享这个的好时机。我在网上看到
a list of fan favorite quotes from D'Angelo. Okay. Here are some really good ones. Top of the list. Colorado, the Sunshine State. Yes. That baby could be the star of a show called Babies I Don't Care About. Everyone I know who skis is dead. I never touched another juggler's instruments. And then is there an animal shelter on the way, Annie Annie Shelto? You know what's really fun about having done those four shows is the gift that keeps on giving, which is the, you know, Greg and Paul obviously thought of that bit of the juggling without my juggling apparatus. We got more mail about that scene. Oh my gosh. People want to hear everything you have
了一份粉丝最喜欢的迪安杰洛金句列表。好的。这里有一些非常棒的。榜首。科罗拉多，阳光之州。是的。那个婴儿可以成为一个名为《我根本不在乎的婴儿》的节目的明星。我认识的所有滑雪的人都死了。我从不碰另一个杂耍艺人的道具。然后去动物园的路上有动物收容所吗，安妮·安妮·谢尔托？你知道演那四集最让人开心的是什么吗，就是那份不断给予的回馈，也就是，你知道的，格雷格和保罗显然想出了那个没有我的杂耍道具却要假装杂耍的点子。我们收到了更多关于那一幕的信件。哦，天哪。人们想听你说的
to say about the juggling. But I remember thinking how and why did you guys think of it this way? I forget what the reason was, but that was just such a genius weirdo thing that he still wants to show off his juggling. Yes. Yeah. He has without any juggling. Yes. And I have now done that bit on stage no less than 20 times. Really? Because it's like a go-to because, you know, people will have like a little charity show or this and that where it's like, would you come do a five minute thing or whatever you
关于杂耍的一切。但我记得当时我在想，你们怎么会以这种方式想到这个，原因是什么？我忘了原因是什么了，但这真是个天才般的怪异点子，他居然还想炫耀他的杂耍。是的。是的。他在没有任何杂耍道具的情况下表演。是的。我现在已经在舞台上表演过这个段子不下20次了。真的吗？因为这是一个现成的保留节目，因为，你知道的，人们会办一个小型慈善演出之类的，问你愿不愿意来表演个五分钟或者你想表演什么？这就像是现成的。太完美了。所以我会上台，然后我会说，只要把我介绍为某某某，说我是个在旧金山渔人码头干了20年的杂耍艺人什么的。所以我走上台，我会开始整段表演，比如，我很抱歉。我走了。我有个小箱子。我会打开它。里面什么都没有。哦，天哪。它们怎么了？我只是，我所有的杂耍球，我都落在另一个箱子里了。我不知道该怎么办，然后哄劝观众说，除非我能在没有它们的情况下完成表演，然后
want to do? It's like ready-made. It's perfect. So I'll come out and I'll say just introduce me as so-and-so and that I'm a juggler who's worked for 20 years down at Fisherman's Wharf in San Francisco or something. So I come out, I do the whole thing of like, I'm so sorry. I left. I have a little case. I'll open up. There'll be nothing in there. Oh my gosh. What's happened to them? I just, all my juggling balls, I left them in my other case. I don't know what to do and then coaxed the audience and like, unless I could just do my act without them and then
大家鼓掌。对，对。然后我做完整套动作。你会把球凭空放在某人的头上吗？是的。我会从观众中拉一个人上来。哦，天哪。我太喜欢那个了。然后我会做那个，而且——我坚信那违反了物理学和重力。那根本不是一个可能的动作。我低声对他们说，尽量一动不动。
everyone applauded. Yeah, yeah. And I do the whole thing. Do you do the balls invisibly on someone's head? Yes. I'll pull someone out of the audience. Oh my gosh. I love that. And then I'll do that and- I believe that defies like physics and gravity. It's not a possible move. And I whisper to them like, stay as still as you can.
人们会把这当真，非常认真对待，他们会坐在椅子上连眼睛都不眨一下，然后我就会把球从他们头上抛过去。我演着同样的戏码，整套动作都做。总之。太神奇了。这就是那份不断给予的回馈。哦，天哪。我最喜欢的其中一部分就是在最后，当球，它落在了你的后脑勺上。是的。
And people will be, take it really seriously and they'll sit in the chair and they won't blink and I'll just throw the balls off their head. And I play the same, I do the whole thing. Anyway. That is amazing. It's the gift that keeps on giving. Oh my gosh. One of my favorite part of it is at the end, when you, it lands on the back of your head. Yes.
是的。你会在那里接住它。然后凯文说，一个球都没掉。对。所以，那绝对是一个高光时刻。是的。对我来说。但同时也是为了强迫你们所有人看着我拍了无数条——
Yes. You're going to catch it there. And Kevin's like, didn't drop a single ball. Right. So that, that was a highlight for sure. Yeah. For me. But also to just have to force you guys to watch it all for how many takes that I-
我——
I saw myself breaking in so many takes with you. So many. So many I would see. And also not just me, but you would see shoulders. Like the shoulders are the dead giveaway. And we were cracking up. And then I just wanted to know, and we had people write in, have you ever juggled? Do you know anything about juggling? No. And I still can't juggle to the set. You can't.
我看到自己跟你拍了很多条都笑场了。非常多。我能看到很多次。不仅是我，你也会看到肩膀在抖。就像肩膀是最大的破绽。我们当时笑得前仰后合。然后我只是想了解，我们有观众写信来问，你曾经玩过杂耍吗？你懂杂耍吗？不懂。而且我到现在还不会在片场玩杂耍。你不会。
You're such a good fake juggler. Yeah. It didn't give me, well, it didn't like spur me on to like, maybe I should really try juggling like and just pretend like I'm faking it pretty well. I still can't do it. I still haven't tried and I still can't do it. Oh, you know what? We have talked about this. Your character has such a great way that he introduces himself to everyone in the bullpen. And we really wanted you to hear it. And then Jenna's going to share with you a second part that didn't make it in that we found in the
你是个很棒的假杂耍高手。对啊。这并没有让我——嗯，它并没有激发我——也许我应该真的去学学杂耍，然后装作自己很擅长的样子。我还是不会。我还是没试过，而且我依然不会。哦，你知道吗？我们之前聊过这个。你的角色有一种非常棒的方式，向休息室里的每个人介绍自己。我们真的很想让你听听这个。然后珍娜会跟你分享一段我们从拍摄剧本中找到的、但没有剪进正片的第二部分。
shooting draft. Okay. Presenting the Angelo Vickers. Hi. Hello. Come on out. Hello. How are you, sir? I'm well, sir. How are you? Can I just say I am, I am so excited to be working here. A little bit about myself. I love the American Southwest for starters. You may call them Arizona, New Mexico, Nevada, Utah. I call them heaven. I have a peanut allergy, something I live with. It's a part
好的。隆重介绍德安吉洛·维克斯。嗨。你好。请进。你好。你好吗，先生？我很好，先生。你好吗？我能说我非常、非常高兴能在这里工作吗？简单介绍一下我自己。首先，我热爱美国西南部。你可以叫它们亚利桑那州、新墨西哥州、内华达州、犹他州。我称它们为天堂。我对花生过敏，这是我生活的一部分。
of me. I've learned to cope with it. What else? I'm just as comfortable at a ballgame as I am at the opera. There was this line where you would have said, I've never ridden a motorcycle. I've had chances. It just doesn't interest me. And I love the idea that in introducing yourself to someone, you include some strangers that does not interest you. Like, here's some stuff about me. A little get to know you. But one thing you need to know, motorcycles do not interest me. And so we were wondering if you had to introduce yourself in the DeAngelo Vickers style. What might you include as your non-interests? Angela's is like hardcore exercise.
这是我的一部分。我已经学会了与它共存。还有什么？我在球场和在歌剧院一样自在。这里本来有一句台词，你会说：我从来没骑过摩托车。我有过机会。只是我没兴趣。我喜欢这种在向别人介绍自己时，把一些跟你毫无关系、你根本不感兴趣的事也加进去的想法。就像，这是关于我的一些事。一个简单的相互了解。但你必须知道的一点是，摩托车对毫无兴趣。所以我们在想，如果你必须用德安吉洛·维克斯的风格介绍自己，你可能会把什么当作你的没兴趣事项？安吉拉的风格就像是硬核运动。
Yeah. If I met a group of people I'd never met before, I might say, hi, my name is Angela. I grew up overseas. I like hummingbirds. I am not interested in anyone yelling at me when I exercise. Okay. Yeah. I would probably say, hi, I'm Will. I'm from Orange County. I do enjoy vigorous exercise, but I have no interest in skydiving. Don't talk to me about skydiving. Did you?
对。如果我遇到一群从未见过的人，我可能会说，嗨，我叫安吉拉。我在海外长大。我喜欢蜂鸟。我对任何人在我运动时对大喊大叫都没有兴趣。好吧。是的。我可能会说，嗨，我是威尔。我来自橙县。我的确喜欢剧烈运动，但我对高空跳伞毫无兴趣。别跟我谈高空跳伞。你呢？
No. No. I've never done it. No. No. I don't want to do it. No. Yeah.
没有。没有。我从来没做过。没有。没有。我不想做。没有。是的。
No. So if you were offered a film or a project that involved a skydiving moment, you would say hard pass. That's going to be a stunt person. That's going to definitely be a stunt person. You're going to need to find someone that looks just like me and have them fall from the sky because I'm not doing it. Because even if I really got talked into it, because I don't know, have you guys had things where you're like, at first you were like, no way, hard pass, and then it's really safe
没有。所以如果有人邀请你拍一部涉及跳伞镜头的电影或项目，你会说绝对拒绝。那得用替身。那绝对得用替身。你们得找一个长得跟我一模一样的人，让他们从天上掉下来，因为我是不会去做的。因为即使我真的被说服了——因为我不知道，你们有没有过那种经历，一开始觉得“绝不，绝对不行”，然后其实很安全……
want to do it this way, and they're like, okay, I can't, I don't know if I could look vivica in the eye and be like, I'm just honey, I'm going to do this skydiving thing. It's going to be totally cool. Your wife would be like, no. Yeah. Yeah. She's going to be like, really? Is it that essential? And like, you're right. Yeah. They can get someone else. Yeah.
想用这种方式做，结果他们说，好吧，我不知道我能不能直视维薇卡的眼睛说，亲爱的，我要去玩这个跳伞了。这绝对酷毙了。你妻子会说，不。对。对。她会说，真的吗？这有那么必要吗？然后，你是对的。对。他们可以找别人。对。
But you have done a lot of stuff. I've done a lot of things that later I was like, why did I, yeah, like I did, I did, I was out in the wilderness with Bear Grylls on the Bear Grylls show and I was hanging from a helicopter. I saw that. Twice. I saw that. And later I was like, I thought, I didn't need to do that.
但你确实做过很多事。我做过很多事，后来回想起来会觉得，我当时为什么要——对，就像我做过，我曾和贝尔·格里尔斯一起去荒野参加贝尔的节目，我挂在直升机上。我看到了。两次。我看到了。后来我想，我觉得，我根本没必要做那个。
Yeah. But I got wrapped up in trying to get Bear Grylls to like me. Wow. I just watched the movie Downhill because I have recently become sort of a skiing fanatic. I just started skiing in my life during the pandemic. I'm slightly upset. I'm leaving today after this interview to go to Utah to ski. This is just so wild to me.
对。但我当时太想让贝尔·格里尔斯喜欢我了。哇。我刚刚看了电影《婚姻风暴》，因为我最近变成了一个滑雪狂热爱好者。我在疫情期间才开始接触滑雪。我有点郁闷。我今天采访结束后就要去犹他州滑雪。这对我来说太疯狂了。
You're taking it on right now in life. Yes. This is your life. Wow. I learned how to ski, put skis on my legs for the first time when I was 46 and I'm turning 49 this year. This is most people learn at an early age. Yes.
你现在才开始接触它。是的。这就是你的人生。哇。我是在46岁第一次把滑雪板穿在腿上，今年我快49岁了。大多数人都是在很小的时候就学会的。是的。
I grew up in Missouri. No skiing there. Not even one? Like a little bunny hill? You know what? I should say there is a place where you can ski. But I mean, come on, let's be honest. It's not really skiing.
我在密苏里州长大。那里没有滑雪。连一个都没有？比如一个小初学者坡？你知道吗？我得说，确实有一个地方可以滑雪。但说实话，我们开诚布公地说吧。那根本算不上滑雪。
I watched Downhill. Are you skiing? Is that you? I'm skiing. Yeah. You're so good. I'm skiing where I fall and do the fall. Right.
我看了《婚姻风暴》。你在滑雪吗？那是你吗？我在滑雪。对。你滑得真好。我在滑雪，然后我摔倒了，表演摔倒。对。
There's a fall part. Right? Yeah. Are we cutting to you at the end when you're already on the ground? After I hit my head on the ground. Yes. Yes. On the thing.
有个摔倒的环节。对吧？对。我们是不是直接切到你已经在地面上的镜头？在我头部撞到地面之后。是的。是的。在那个东西上。
Yeah. Okay. That was me acting after I hit my head. Yes. It was very good. I'm going to add that to your Wikipedia. Your Wikipedia. Injury comedy.
对。好吧，那是我撞到头之后的演技。是的。非常棒。我要把它加到你的维基百科上。你的维基百科。受伤喜剧。
Yeah. Injury comedy. Injury comedy, which is, again, under the category of anti-humor. It is. Anti-humor. Yeah. But no, all that other skiing is you. That's me.
对。受伤喜剧。受伤喜剧，这再次属于反幽默的范畴。确实如此。反幽默。是的。不过说真的，其他那些滑雪镜头都是你。那是我。
But Julia Louis-Dreyfus, she's an excellence gear. She was very good in the film as well. She can do the moguls and everything. I can't quite do the moguls. No. Okay. So, the movie you're referring to, we shot in Austria, and that's a whole, another kind of, how do you describe it?
但是茱莉亚·路易斯-德利法斯，她是个滑雪高手。她在电影里也非常厉害。她能滑雪包和各种地形。我实在是不太会滑雪包。好吧。所以，你提到的这部电影，我们是在奥地利拍摄的，那是另一种……你怎么形容它？
Let's just say the Austrians are not afraid to cut in line. Oh, oh. Or whoosh right in front of you. Like you really have to be aggressive. It's a different cultural agreement. It's seen as their national sport. And so everyone skis and there were times when you're, cause there's a certain etiquette
只能说奥地利人一点也不怕插队。哦，哦。或者直接从你面前呼啸而过。你真的必须很有侵略性。这是一种不同的文化契约。这被视为他们的国民运动。所以每个人都滑雪，有时候当你在……因为有一种特定的礼仪
and waiting in the lift line where, you know, we give ourselves a little space in between. There would be some guy would have his ski jammed in between my legs, pressed up against my back and I would look back to give the non-verbal like, hello, and he, this person just looked straight ahead and then keep scooting and like pressing against my shoulder blade.
就是在缆车队伍里等待的时候，你知道的，我们会给自己留一点空间。总会有某个家伙把他的滑雪板卡在我的双腿之间，紧紧贴着我的后背，我会回过头去发出一个非语言的信号，比如“你好”，而这个人只是目视前方，然后继续往前蹭，一直紧贴着我的肩膀。
And I thought, oh, this is just the way they do it. That, that was weird. And the other thing was you'd get to the top of a beautiful mountain riding the gondola and then there's just cigarette butts everywhere. Really? Yeah, it was so bizarre. Just this, you just look out
我想，哦，他们就是这样做的。这，这太诡异了。还有一件事是，当你坐缆车到达美丽的山顶时，到处都是烟头。真的吗？是的，太离谱了。你只要放眼望去
and just this beautiful landscape and then littered with cigarette butts. So ski Austria. So ski Austria. So I would do, do you guys know? I'm so sorry. I feel, this is, or is this like a paid commercial for ski Austria because.
就是这样美丽的风景，然后到处都是烟头。所以，去奥地利滑雪吧。所以，去奥地利滑雪吧。所以我会……你们知道吗？我很抱歉。我觉得，这，这难道是奥地利滑雪局的付费广告吗，因为……
Were you here today? Is that why you're here? Well, did you bait me into talking about skiing? If you fly into. Hashtag. Hashtag. Stay at the hotel. There was one of the towns.
你今天是为此而来的吗？这就是你来这儿的原因吗？好吧，你是故意引诱我聊滑雪的吗？如果你坐飞机来……标签。标签。住在酒店。有一个小镇……
Use code. The town that. Use code, will 40 for 40% off your first night out there. What happens in Ishkel stays in Ishkel. Hashtag, cigarette butts. Hashtag, cigarette butts. I don't even know where we are. I don't know where we are either.
使用优惠码。那个小镇……使用优惠码 Will 40，首次入住即可享受 40% 的折扣。在伊施格尔发生的，就留在伊施格尔。标签，烟头。标签，烟头。我甚至不知道我们在哪儿。我也不知道我们在哪儿。
I don't either. I love it. I have something. I read that when you were in college, you worked at a small town television station. Yes, this was just local cable. Oh. Around and about Orange County news.
我也不知道。我喜欢这样。我有一件事。我看到你上大学时，曾在一个小镇电视台工作。对，这只是当地的有线电视。哦。橙县新闻周边及其他。
Oh, I love that. Seen by no one. Was this before you had decided to go into acting? Like, was this like, maybe I'll do this? Well, I was, I had my degree in sports information. Mm-hmm. Oh. Real major.
哦，我喜欢这个。根本没人看。这是在你决定从事表演之前吗？这就像是，也许我可以做这个？嗯，我当时拿的是体育信息学位。嗯哼。哦。真正的专业。
You know what, that's how you learn. That's like the class I took called Ideas of Mathematics. Like me and the defensive line of a football team. Oh, right, right. We just talked about ideas of math, just ideas. Yeah, just ideas. General notions. That was basically sports journalism degree.
你知道吗，这就是学习的方式。就像我选过的一门课叫“数学的理念”。就像我和一支橄榄球队的防守锋线一样。哦，对，对。我们只是谈论数学的理念，仅仅是理念。对，只是理念。一些一般概念。那基本上就算是个体育新闻学位。
OK. So that's kind of where I thought I was going to, that was a more legit way to get into entertainment. And so I was, I had my degree, but I was, I didn't really have a job. It's not like I got hired out of college. I moved back home and I started working at this local cable thing.
好吧。所以这就是我当时想去的地方，那是一种更正规的进入娱乐界的方式。所以我有学位，但我其实没有工作。并不是说我一毕业就被录用了。我搬回了家，开始在这家本地的有线电视台工作。
And so I did that for like a year and a half. And I'd heard like people had gotten hired out of there and had, you know, because the whole thing is to put together a tape that you send out. And so while I was doing that, though, I thought, I remember there was a, they had really good press credentials to like go to, they needed someone to go to the LA Rams game. And you had press credentials.
我干了一年半左右。我听说有人从那里被录用过，而且，你知道的，因为整个流程就是制作一盘磁带寄出去。不过在我干那个的时候，我记得有一个，他们有很好的记者证去参加，他们需要有人去洛杉矶公羊队的比赛。而且你有记者证。
You could like get on the field and stuff. You could get on the field and like interview the coach and all the stuff like that. They were like, so we need someone to go do this and everyone's hand shot up. And my first thought was like, what day is that? Do I really? Oh, I got something on Sunday.
你可以进到球场里面之类的。你可以进到球场里去采访教练之类的。他们当时说，我们需要有人去干这个，所有人的手都举起来了。我的第一反应是，那是哪天？我真的要去吗？哦，我周日有事。
Yeah. Maybe I don't really want to do it. And I, it wasn't like, oh gosh, I need that for my tape, which is what you have to have. Yes. Mine was more like, who can I, I got to bring a friend to operate the camera and oh, it's going to be a pain. And I thought, oh, that's-
对。也许我并不是真的很想去。而且我，感觉并不像是，哦天哪，我需要这个来做我的作品集，那是你必须要有的。是的。我的想法更像是，我能找谁，我得带个朋友去操作摄像机，哦，这太麻烦了。我想，哦，那——
I can't wear shorts. Right. I thought that's not a good sign. That kind of coincided with, I just started thinking, oh, I'm going to have to try to go for this comedy thing because I keep thinking about- Doing bits. Doing bits and wanting to do it.
我不能穿短裤。对。我觉得这不是个好兆头。这恰好与我开始产生的一个想法不谋而合，哦，我得去尝试搞搞笑喜剧这一行，因为我一直在想——现挂。现挂，而且很想去干这个。
And I would go and I would sit at the improv in Irvine and sit in the back of the room at an open mic night and almost sign my name to the list, but be too afraid and go consecutive weeks and just watch three hours of comedy and sit there and think, well, that person, oh, they're terrible. Yeah. I'm much better than them.
我会去欧文市的即兴喜剧俱乐部，坐在开放麦之夜房间的最后面，差点把我的名字签到名单上，但又太害怕了，连续几个星期只看不表演，坐在那儿看三个小时的喜剧，心想，好吧，那个人，哦，他们太糟糕了。对。我比他们强多了。
They should have set it up like this. Yeah. Yeah. Or, ooh, they're really good. And I would just like kind of see what- And so I was kind of doing that. I started taking my first class at the groundlings. I was taking some acting class.
他们本该这样安排的。对。对。或者，哦，他们真的很棒。我就会去看看——所以我基本上在做这些。我开始在“地民”剧团上第一节课。我上了一些表演课。
So I was kind of doing all that while I was working at the news station and then the comedy went out. You found your passion. Yeah. Yeah. And it was that I didn't really want to be a new- I wanted to be Chevy Chase doing the news. I didn't want to actually be doing the news.
所以我一边在新闻台工作，一边在做这些，然后喜剧就胜出了。你找到了你的热情。对。对。其实我并不是真的很想做新——我想成为那种在节目里播新闻的切维·蔡斯。我并不是真的想去播新闻。
Right. That is what kind of came through. I once did a news story. I did a story on there was a team of goats that the city of Laguna Beach would hire to clear all the brush as a way of fire mitigation. Right, right. So I did a story on that.
没错。这就是当时的感觉。我曾经做过一则新闻报道。我做过一个报道，是关于拉古纳海滩市雇佣了一群山羊来清理所有的灌木丛，以此作为防火措施。对，对。所以我做了一个关于这个的报道。
It was not a great piece of journalism at all. Super dry. Like, I wish I had copies of these stories. There's about 15 goats here today. Yeah, yeah. I'm in front of the Laguna Beach. You know, it's like super stiff and this and that. But I noticed when I filmed some of the goats,
那根本算不上什么优秀的新闻作品。超级枯燥。就像，我真希望我有这些报道的备份。今天这里大约有15只山羊。对，对。我在拉古纳海滩的前面。你知道的，就超级生硬之类的。但我注意到当我拍摄一些山羊的镜头时，
some of the footage, they looked like they were singing. So I did the story as much of it as there was to tell a story. And then I just added opera music to these goats. See? The, it blew the guy who ran the station who was our editor and also the teacher of the club. It was like, that's the way you do a story. You added a little pizzazz.
有些镜头里，它们看起来像是在唱歌。所以我把这则报道做成了能讲多少算多少的故事。然后我只是给这些山羊加上了歌剧音乐。你看？这让管理电视台的家伙惊艳到了，他既是我们的剪辑师，也是俱乐部的老师。当时他说，这才是做报道的方式。你加了一点情趣。
It was hilarious and I was like, wasn't that one? She made that goat story really pop. Yeah. And I was like, I thought, oh, that's funny. I'm more interested in messing around. I could never do anything in front of a group of people without doing a bit. And you know, you can't do bits with strangers
这太搞笑了，当时我想，那不是挺好的吗？她把那个山羊的故事做得很出彩。对。然后我想，哦，这挺搞笑的。我对瞎胡闹更感兴趣。如果在⼀群⼈⾯前我从来没法不好好说话，总得抖个包袱。你知道的，你不能和陌生人抖包袱，
for the most part, if they don't land. But like, I was in charge of basically like the minutes in my sorority and I would get up. My fraternity was a big stage for me as well. Yes. So I had to get up and sort of say how the, you know, the pledge dance went and what everyone ate. And I just started doing all these bits.
基本上如果包袱没响的话。但是，比如，我负责我们姐妹会的会议记录，我会站起来。我的兄弟会对我来说也是个大舞台。没错。所以我不得不站起来，说说，你知道的，宣誓舞会进行得怎么样，大家都吃了什么。我开始疯狂抖包袱。
And it was like crickets. There were like three gals that laughed. And then I also offended a few people because I guess they, I did a bit about the chicken dish and there was a big deal. I guess there was a committee that voted on this chicken dish and they were really pissed off at me. And I, but I just couldn't wait to get up there again the next week and give minutes.
结果就像冷场了一样。只有大约三个人笑了。然后我还得罪了一些人，因为我想，我讲了一个关于鸡肉菜肴的笑话，那是个大事件。我猜有一个委员会对这道鸡肉菜进行过投票，他们对我很生气。虽然如此，我还是迫不及待地想在下周再次站上去做会议记录。
But did you slowly win them over? In a way? Some. Not all. The answer is no. Yeah. But I couldn't wait to get, I was like, oh, I, what am I, I can't get up there.
但你慢慢赢得他们的认可了吗？某种程度上？有的人有。并非全部。答案是没有。对。但我迫不及待地想去，当时我想，哦，我，怎么回事，我怎么能不上台呢。
It was your first open mic. I did the same thing. I was our song chairman. And so during the chapter of me, there was no, there was no reason for the song chairman to ever speak. You were like, once again, we need to hear from the song chairman. I made the song chairman's report.
那是你的第一个开放麦。我也是这么干的。我是我们的歌曲主席。所以在那段期间，歌曲主席根本没有理由说话。你会想，再一次，我们需要听听歌曲主席的发言。我做了歌曲主席的报告。
And I had Monday night class, so I couldn't be there. So I tape recorded a report and it became this thing. And they would play it? They would play it and everyone would be like, shh, everyone be quiet. And so they would play the song chairman's report. And I would just, I'd make fun of people in the house. I would do this, I would do that and became a huge hit.
我星期一晚上有课，所以不能去。所以我录下了报告，这成了一件轰动的事。他们会放这段录音？他们会放这段录音，每个人都会说，嘘，大家都安静。于是他们就会播放歌曲主席的报告。而我就开始拿屋里的人开涮。我会这样，我会那样，结果大获成功。
I don't think I became a hit. Yeah, yeah. Do you consider Saturday Night Live like your quote unquote big break? Or was there something before that that really felt like your big break? Yeah, no question. That was definitely, I mean, there was,
我觉得我没获得成功。对，对。你认为《周六夜现场》是你的所谓“重大突破”吗？还是说之前有什么事让你真觉得是重大突破？对，毫无疑问。那绝对是，我的意思是，曾经有，
there was one week when I was still, before I auditioned for Saturday Night Live, there was a week here in LA where I got three jobs in one week. Now they were all like five and on, they were like one line each. Yeah, but still, that feels huge. I landed three different, on three different sitcoms.
有那么一周，我还在，在我去《周六夜现场》试镜之前，我在洛杉矶的一周内得到了三份工作。虽然它们都是那种只有五行台词的龙套，每人一句台词那种。是的，但即便如此，这也感觉很了不起。我拿下了三个不同的，在三个不同的情景喜剧里。
That almost was like, I still think of that, and I like got, it was then just after, got my after a card from, you know. You're official, you're in the union. And so I remember, so that was huge. And then of course, yeah, the Saturday Night Live thing was all bonkers. How long had you been a struggling actor
这几乎让我觉得，我到现在还这么想，我拿到了，就在之后，拿到了来自，你知道的，演员工会的会员卡。你正式成为工会成员了。所以我记得，那太棒了。然后当然，是的，《周六夜现场》那件事完全就是个疯狂的奇迹。
or an aspiring actor before you landed on Saturday Night Live? Let's see, I would have graduated college in 90 and I got on the show in, I was hired this summer of 95. So about five years? Yeah, yeah. Knocking around. Yeah.
在你加入《周六夜现场》之前，你作为一个苦苦挣扎的演员或是有抱负的演员有多久了？让我想想，我90年大学毕业，我加入这个节目是在，我是在95年夏天被雇用的。所以大约五年？对，对。四处碰壁。对。
Just got your after card. Just got, yeah. Yeah, yeah. That's pretty cool. Doing, yeah, doing whatever like we all were. Yeah. Finding any sort of like variety show in LA. Did you have any odd jobs while you were a struggling actor?
刚拿到工会卡。刚拿到，对。对，对。挺酷的。在做，对，就像我们所有人一样在做任何事。对。在洛杉矶寻找任何种类的综艺节目。你在苦苦挣扎当演员的时候做过什么副业吗？
I answered phones. Did you really? I answered phones at a real estate auction company. What is that? And then I answered phones at a art auction company, which my friend, now wife, Vivica got me the job. So I was an appraisal coordinator. At Butterfield and Butterfield.
我接听过电话。真的吗？我在一家房地产拍卖公司接电话。那是什么？后来我在一家艺术品拍卖公司接电话，我现在的妻子、当时的朋友维维卡帮我找的工作。所以我是一名估价协调员。在巴特菲尔德拍卖行。
You appraised art? No, I typed up the appraisal. You typed it up. Yeah. Coordinator, coordinator. I coordinated. Right, the appraisal. Yes, let's, yeah.
你鉴定艺术品？不，我把鉴定结果打出来。你把它打印出来。对。协调员，协调员。我负责协调。对，估价。是的，我们来，对。
No, I got hired at SNL and still worked at the auction company for another month. Oh. Because they didn't, they weren't gonna pay you till the first week of the show. And I had bills to pay. But there were other coworkers, I'd be in my cubicle and they're like,
不，我被《SNL》录用了，但还在拍卖公司又工作了一个月。哦。因为他们，节目第一周之前他们不会给你发工资。而我还有账单要付。但还有其他同事，我坐在隔局间里，他们会说，
hey, didn't you get on Saturday Night Live? I'm like, yep, I sure did. But I gotta get through this stack of appraisals before I leave. We got a fan question from Natalie Dee. Okay. All right. Natalie wanted to know,
嘿，你不是上了《周六夜现场》吗？我说，对，没错。但我得在我离开之前把这堆估价表处理完。我们收到了来自娜塔莉·迪的一个粉丝提问。好的。好的。娜塔莉想知道，
how did you keep a straight face without laughing, especially in the scene with Ed Helms, where you make him eat soap? And Jess Renee asked, if you ever break in scenes. Well, that was gonna be my answer to Natalie. I have a superpower of, I'm really good at not breaking. This is what we remember about you. This is what we remember about you.
你是怎么忍住不笑保持扑克脸的，尤其是和埃德·海尔姆斯演对手戏、逼他吃肥皂的那场戏？杰斯·雷内问，你在拍戏时有没有笑场过。好吧，这就是我对娜塔莉的回答。我有一种超能力，我非常擅长忍住不笑。这就是大家对我们的记忆。这就是大家对我们的记忆。
And also my daughter loves bloopers. So we ended up finding bloopers and we watched these bloopers of Talladega Nights. And everyone is losing it. And you are like a statue. Right. No, I never, it would only happen like twice a year. Yeah.
而且我女儿非常喜欢花絮。所以我们最后找到了花絮，我们观看了《塔拉迪加之夜》的花絮。所有人都笑崩了。而你就像一尊雕像。对。不，我从不，这种情况一年也就发生个两次吧。对。
Unlike Saturday Night Live or something. And a lot of times though, there are times when I can tell I'm breaking, but no one else can tell. Right, right. So I hide it really well. I could tell, not that you were breaking, but that you were genuinely surprised
不像在《周六夜现场》或者别的节目里。不过很多时候，其实有些时候我能看出自己在笑场，但别人看不出来。对，对。所以我伪装得很好。我看得出来，倒不是说你笑场了，而是你真的大吃一惊
when Ed put the soap in his mouth because that wasn't scripted and it was real soap. And I think you just improvised for him to try the soap. And then when he did, you can see your face, you're like, hey, it felt like you were doing just like a prank on him, like do this thing. Like there were all these scripted things, absurd things you were gonna ask him to do.
当埃德把肥皂放进嘴里的时候，因为那不是剧本里写的，而且那是真肥皂。我觉得你只是即兴让他试一下那个肥皂。然后当他真这么做了，你能看到你的表情，你就像是在说，嘿，感觉你只是在对他恶作剧，比如做这个。就像你要求他做的那些剧本里的、荒谬的事情一样。
And you're like, how about eat the soap? And it felt like a personal challenge and Ed took you up on it and the look in your eyes is a little bit like, whoa, well, okay. That's so funny, yeah. One question before we take a break. Do you remember the stunt gone wrong in the warehouse? We were talking about when stunts can go wrong.
然后你说，要不要吃个肥皂？感觉就像是一个个人的挑战，而埃德接受了你的挑战，你眼神里的表情有点像，哇，好吧，行。太搞笑了，对。在休息之前还有一个问题。你还记得仓库里的那个特技失误吗？我们之前在讨论特技什么时候会出问题。
Yes. We got to talk to Greg about it. We got to talk to Randy Cordray, who was our production manager at the time. They all just want to say sorry again for basically just catapulting you into a basketball hoop. No, I don't remember it go. You're thinking of something else?
记得。我们得和格雷格聊聊这个。我们得跟兰迪·科德雷聊聊，他当时是我们的制作经理。他们都只是想再次为把你“投石机一样”弹射到一个篮球框里而道歉。不，我不记得出过事。你是不是在想别的？
Oh no, I just thought you meant the- Like story-wise. The story-wise. You don't remember when we actually almost like- No. Gave you a real concussion. They had the pulley and they- Did it go?
哦不，我以为你指的是那个——剧情方面的。剧情方面的。你不记得当时我们实际上差不多——不。真的把你弄得轻微脑震荡了吗？他们用了滑轮，然后——出事了吗？
They are gonna be so relieved that you don't remember this. Oh my gosh, they have carried this around for a year. No, because I was just watching it. Because I remembered when I revisited the episode going, oh, that's right, we do the thing. I go for the basketball dunk and it falls on me, but it's all off camera, da, da, da. But no, I don't remember.
他们要是知道你不记得这事了，一定会如释重负的。哦天哪，他们把这事记在心里整整一年了。没有，因为我刚刚还在看那个片段。因为我记得当我重新看那一集时，心想，哦，对了，我们有那个情节。我冲过去扣篮然后它砸在我身上，但这些都是镜头外完成的，啦啦啦。但真的，我不记得了。
Oh, did something go awry? Well, yes, so what happened? Greg said as they designed this pulley thing and Greg said just as he looked at it, he thought the physics were off on it and they put you in it and the first take, they were, as you jumped, these guys were gonna pull this thing
哦，有什么地方出岔子了吗？嗯，是的，事情是这样的。格雷格说他们设计了这个滑轮装置，格雷格说他一看到它，就觉得物理原理不太对劲，他们把你挂上去，第一次拍摄时，他们说，当你跳起来的时候，这些家伙会拉动这个东西，
and then you were gonna go up a little bit. And the first time, they didn't quite get you there. And they were like, okay, we'll do it again. You guys, we gotta pull harder. So the second time you went to do the jump and they yanked it and you went flying into the backboard. And I guess you got like a big cut on your knee. No.
然后你就会往上升一点。第一次，他们没完全把你拉到位。他们就说，好吧，我们再来一次。伙计们，我们得拉得更用力点。所以第二次你准备去跳的时候，他们猛地一拉，你就飞向了篮板。我猜你的膝盖还划破了个大口子。没有。
Yes, and we were all just like mortified. We were mortified. How do I not have a memory of this? I don't, you probably blocked it out because of the trauma. And then they were like, you don't have to do it again. Don't even worry about it. And you're like, no, no, no, no, I got one more.
是的，我们当时都吓坏了。我们吓坏了。我怎么会完全不记得这事了？我不，你可能因为创伤把它给选择性遗忘了吧。然后他们说，你不用再拍了。连想都别想了。而你却说，不，不，不，不，我还能再来一次。再拍一次吧。然后他们就拍了那次，就那样了。
Let's do one more. And then they got that one, that was it. The only thing I do remember about that sequence is editorially, I said the funniest, strongest, kind of darkest thing is that D'Angelo is dead. I do remember you pitching that. And I was like, that's the funniest thing. That's like the funniest way.
我对那个桥段唯一的记忆是，从剪辑的角度来看，我说过最搞笑、最有力、也最黑暗的一句话就是“安杰洛死了”。我确实记得你提出了这个点子。当时我就觉得，那是最好笑的事。那简直是最好笑的方式。
We kill you. Yes. But then they're like, okay, just for safety, let's just shoot this thing. And I was like, oh, this is going in. Yeah. Where I'm walking through the office with my head bandaged.
我们把你写死了。是的。但随后他们说，好吧，为了安全起见，我们还是把这个拍了吧。然后我说，哦，这个绝对能播。对。就是我脑袋缠着绷带走过办公室的那个画面。
Oh no, I know. I laughed through all your takes. You see me laughing. Fans just pointed it out. They're like, Angelo, you're not even, you did. I did see you on that one. You know why? Because, okay, here's the thing.
哦不，我懂。我在你所有的镜头里都在笑。粉丝们都指出来了。他们说，安杰洛，你甚至没有，你确实笑了。我在那个镜头里确实看到你笑了。你知道为什么吗？因为，好吧，事情是这样的。
First of all, whatever you're the funniest person on the planet, there's that. But no, no. But then on top of it, you give someone who is so flippin' funny, gibberish words, and then you never did them the same. So every time I would get used to you being like face to face for it,
首先，不管你是不是地球上最搞笑的人，这是其一。但是，不，不。而且最重要的是，你给一个极其搞笑的人一堆胡言乱语的台词，而且你每次说的都不一样。所以每次我习惯了你面对着我拍的时候，
then the next time I'd be like, yeah, I was like, I can't. I can't. But that was the only thing I do really remember. So that's crazy. I don't remember cutting my leg open, but I do remember going, ugh. I wish they would've just killed me. They should've killed me off.
接下来我就会想，是的，当时我就觉得，我受不了。我受不了。但这确实是我唯一真正记得的事。所以这太疯狂了。我不记得自己腿上划破了个大口子，但我确实记得当时心里在想，呃。我真希望他们直接把我写死算了。他们本该把我写死的。
That'd be so funny. Yeah. Like whatever happened to Angelo. There was a, in the shooting draft, there was. I guess it was too. It was too dark. Too dark for the guys. Because we have the shooting drafts,
那多搞笑啊。对。就像安杰洛后来怎么了。在拍摄剧本里，确实有。我猜也是。这也太黑暗了。对大家来说太黑暗了。因为我们有拍摄剧本，
there was a scene where the ambulance is taking you away. And Daryl says to Andy, is he gonna be okay? And Andy goes, I don't, they said no. That's what I'm saying. That's so funny. It's so funny. Yes. That would've been so good.
其中有一场戏是救护车把你拉走。然后达里尔对安迪说，他会没事吧？安迪回答说，我不知道，他们说不行。这就是我想说的。太搞笑了。太搞笑了。是的。那本来会很棒的。
They said no. No. Boy, how did I not remember getting slammed into the backboard? I don't know. Wow. They are gonna be so relieved. I mean, I'm gonna call this afternoon.
他们说不行。不。天哪，我怎么会不记得自己被猛撞到篮板上去了？我不知道。哇。他们听到这消息绝对会如释重负的。我的意思是，我下午就要打电话。
I know. I feel like guys, Will has no memory. They're gonna be like, what's his problem? We asked Greg about it. Did he not? We asked Greg about it. And the first thing he said was, oh, I still think about that constantly.
我知道。我觉得大家会想，威利根本没记忆。他们肯定会觉得，他到底有什么毛病？我们问过格雷格这事了。他没提吗？我们问过格雷格了。他说的第一句话就是，哦，我一直在想这件事。
Really? Yeah. Oh, please tell him, until this moment. And even now, I'm not picturing it happening. Wow. Oh, I'm texting Greg. Yeah. Okay, well, let's take a break.
真的吗？对。哦，请告诉他，直到刚才那一刻之前。甚至现在，我脑子里都想象不出那个画面发生过。哇。哦，我得给格雷格发个短信。对。好吧，我们休息一下吧。
And when we come back, we have a regular guide quiz for you. Yeah, we just ask you questions that a regular guy would answer. Okay. We'll see if you're a regular guy. All right, Will, we're back from our break. We're gonna give you the regular guide questions.
等我们回来，我们要给你来个“普通人测验”。对，就是问你一些普通人会回答的问题。好的。我们来看看你到底是不是个普通人。好吧，威利，我们休息回来了。我们要给你出普通人的问题。
These are the real, like, hard-hitting stuff. Yeah, I know. If you're ready, this is the part where... It'll prove if I'm a regular guy. Yeah. I can feel it. Okay, question number one. Everyone's really crowded around the windows of the studio.
这些都是真正那种、直击要害的硬核问题。对，我知道。如果你准备好了，这就是……这能证明我是不是个普通人。对。我能感觉到。好吧，问题一。每个人都挤在工作室的窗户周围。
I know. We've got a few succulents looking in. What do you eat for breakfast? I usually eat, I love this Ezekiel's brand cereal. Mm-hmm. Is it like a muesli sort of thing? It's kind of like a more of like a grape nuts-y thing. Okay.
我知道。我们有几盆多肉植物在往里看。你早餐吃什么？我通常吃，我超喜欢这款Ezekiel牌麦片。嗯哼。它是那种类似瑞士什锦早餐的东西吗？它有点更接近葡萄坚果麦片（Grape-Nuts）那种东西。好吧。
Is that every morning? Are you the same breakfast every day? Not necessarily. Oh, you mix it up. I mix it up. Okay. Okay. Where's your protein in the morning?
那是每天早晨都吃吗？你每天早餐都吃一样的东西吗？不一定。哦，你会换着吃。我换着吃。好吧。好吧。你早上的蛋白质从哪里摄取？
It's in the cereal. Okay. I'm just checking. Yeah. All right. What is one of your favorite places you've visited in the United States? One of, well,
就在麦片里。好吧。我只是确认一下。Yeah。好吧。你在美国去过的地方里，最喜欢哪个地方？其中一个，呃，
really? Yeah. I love New York City. Duh. Who doesn't? It's a great place. I love it. City that never saves.
真的吗？是啊。我爱纽约市。废话。谁不爱？那是个好地方。我爱死那儿了。不夜城。
I want to retire there. There, it's always surprising to me how you rediscover that city every time you visit. That is true. You're speaking to my soul. Right. There's just so many nooks and crannies in a new place here in Azizah and this museum,
我想在那里退休。在那里，每次你去的时候都能重新发现那个城市的美，这总是让我感到惊喜。确实如此。说到我心坎里去了。对。那里面有好多角角落落，在阿齐萨（Azizah）这样一个新地方还有这个博物馆，
and it blows my mind. Love it. It blows my mind. But I also just went to Portland. Portland, it's a little hidden gem, maybe not so hidden now, but Portland's great. Yeah.
让我大开眼界。太棒了。让我大开眼界。但我最近也去了波特兰。波特兰，算是一个小众宝藏吧，虽然现在可能没那么小众了，但波特兰真的很棒。是啊。
Have you been? No. I love Portland. I love the Oregon coast. Great restaurants, little coffee places, like cool bike paths and walking trails, and- So green.
你去过吗？没有。我超爱波特兰。我喜欢俄勒冈海岸。很棒的餐厅、小咖啡馆，还有酷炫的自行车道和步行小径，以及——太绿意盎然了。
I love a city feel to it if you need that, but then really great neighborhoods. In general, are you more city or more like rural kind of, like do you like a kind of like hiking, kind of outdoorsy thing, or do you like city? Do any of it,
如果你需要的话，我喜欢它的城市氛围，但同时又有非常棒的街区。总的来说，你更喜欢城市还是更偏向乡村那种，比如你喜欢远足、亲近大自然那种，还是喜欢城市？哪种都可以，
because I can kind of adjust wherever I am, but my wife's definitely more city, and I love cities too, so I'll go city. Okay. Okay. What was the make and model of your first car? It was a 1969 Powder Blue VW Bug. Aw.
因为我在哪里都能适应，但我的妻子绝对更喜欢城市，我也很喜欢城市，所以我会选城市。好吧。好吧。你的第一辆车的品牌和型号是什么？是一辆1969年的粉蓝色大众甲壳虫。啊。
Do you wish you still had it? It's kind of amazing. I had a COVID midlife purchase where I bought a 61 VW bus with the 23 windows around the top. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yes. Like surf green, blue with white trim.
你希望现在还留着它吗？这挺神奇的。我在疫情期间经历了一次中年购物冲动，买了一辆61年的大众巴士，车顶四周有23扇窗户。对，对，对。是的。就像冲浪绿，带白色饰边的蓝色。
It was like beautiful. Oh my gosh. But I just sold it again because it made me too nervous to drive it, because it was in like mint condition. Right. It was too special. It was too special, but then I'd feel guilty about not driving it,
它简直美极了。哦天哪。但我刚刚又把它卖了，因为它让我开车时太紧张了，因为它处于那种崭新的状态。没错。它太特别了。它太特别了，但接着我又会为不开它而感到内疚，
and then I felt guilty about when I drove it because I didn't want to get dinged and I just couldn't handle. It was a stressful purchase. Exactly, I don't think I'll ever be like a car guy that way. I get it. So, regular guy. Pretty regular guy.
然后当我开它的时候我又会感到内疚，因为我不想让它被刮蹭，我简直无法应付。那是一次压力重重的购物。没错，我想我永远不会成为那种车迷。我懂。所以，是个普通人。挺普通的普通人。
Okay, this one hits close to home with me. How many emails are your inbox? Do you keep a tidy box or do you let them pile up? Very tidy. Okay. The answer stuff. I cleared the decks right away. How many do I have?
好吧，这个话题戳中了我的痛点。你的收件箱里有多少封邮件？你保持收件箱整洁还是任由它们堆积？非常整洁。好吧。及时处理事情。我立刻把邮件清理干净。我有多少封？
1,700. Yeah, how does that make you feel when you read that Angela has 1,700 emails? Does that, I can't handle it. It bothers me. I can't handle it. I don't like it when she shows it to me. Sorry.
1700封。是啊，当你看到安吉拉有1700封未读邮件时，你作何感想？这会，我受不了。这让我抓狂。我受不了。她拿给我看的时候我可不喜欢。抱歉。
It gives me heart palpitations. Sorry. Listen, I'm chipping away at it. Yeah. Next one. If you are in charge of cooking dinner, what is your go-to dish? I can't even say.
这让我心跳加速。抱歉。听着，我正在一点点清理呢。好吧。下一个。如果你负责做晚餐，你的拿手菜是什么？我甚至说不出来。
What? Do you not? I don't ever cook dinner. Who cooks? Viv does. Well, that's good. You're lucky. You have a person who does the dinners.
什么？你不做吗？我从来不做晚餐。谁做？维夫（Viv）做。嗯，那挺好的。你真幸运。你有个负责做晚饭的人。
My husband always cooks. Really? Yeah, I don't cook. I need to. I need to get a dish. We need a go-to dish. I know. I don't have one.
我丈夫总是做饭。真的吗？对，我不做饭。我需要。我得学道菜。我们需要一道拿手菜。我知道。我没有。
You should take a cooking class together. Get a go-to dish. You should get a go-to called. Oh my God. There should be a cooking school called. Go-to dish. Go-to dish. Yeah.
你们应该一起去上烹饪课。学道拿手菜。你们应该去上一门叫。哦天哪。应该有一所烹饪学校叫。拿手菜（Go-to dish）。拿手菜（Go-to dish）。是啊。
Because you go to learn, but you also go to dish. Dish. Did you hear about this? Yeah, and I know. That's too much Parmesan. I told her no way. I got wrapped up in the dish.
因为你去学习，但你也是去八卦（dish）。八卦（Dish）。你听说过这个吗？对，而且我知道。那是加了太多帕玛森芝士。我告诉她绝对不行。我太专注于这个“盘子（dish）”了。
Now I have to focus back on this dish. That's actually pretty great. Go-to dish. What's your go-to board game? Do you have a family board game? The go-to game right now is celebrity. Yeah, love it. So the kids, we started doing it on ski trips
现在我得把注意力重新集中回这道菜上。这其实挺棒的。拿手菜。你最拿手的桌游是什么？你们家有什么家庭桌游吗？现在最拿手的游戏是“名人猜词”（celebrity）。对，超爱。所以孩子们，我们开始在滑雪旅行时玩这个，
and they go crazy. They love trying to trip us up with, YouTubers and people like that. Oh, forget it. Trying to act out, yeah, pop culture people that we don't know anymore and it cracks them up. But then we get them back with.
他们玩得超级疯狂。他们喜欢用油管博主之类的人来给我们设套。哦，别提了。试图表演出来，是的，那些我们已经不认识的流行文化人物，这让他们乐不可支。但随后我们会用……来反击他们。
The oldies. Martin Van Buren. We were playing with my family and I was trying, I had Jennifer Aniston. And my sister Janet was like, I don't know who that is. I was like, yes, you do. No, don't know.
老一辈名人。马丁·范布伦（Martin Van Buren）。我和我的家人在玩，我当时试着，我抽到了詹妮弗·安妮斯顿。我妹妹珍妮（Janet）就说，我不知道那是谁。我说，不，你绝对知道。不，不知道。
I'm like, oh. Okay, how early do you get to the airport before a flight? I'm like, I'm pretty much a rule follower. I like the two hour thing. But here's my rule though. If I'm late, I don't run. I don't run to catch that flight. What so what happens, dude?
我说，哦。好吧，你通常在航班起飞前多久到达机场？我这人嘛，基本上是个遵守规则的人。我喜欢留出两个小时。但这是我的原则。如果我迟到了，我不会跑。我不会为了赶那个航班而奔跑。那，那会发生什么，老兄？
You walk slowly? I almost, to punish. What is great rule? Because it won't be, I'm not the reason we're late. I'll just leave it at that. Oh, so I'm not gonna have to. But I'll slow walk it. Okay, if everyone wants to be this late,
你慢悠悠地走？我几乎是，为了惩罚。这是多么棒的原则？因为那不会是，我才不是我们迟到的原因。我就直说了吧。哦，所以我才不要。但我会慢吞吞地走。好吧，如果每个人都想这么迟，
we're gonna miss our flight. There's consequences. There's consequences. Right. Get your act together, let's be ready. That'll teach them. Plan better. I don't know why.
我们就要错过航班了。这是有后果的。这是有后果的。没错。振作点，准备好。这能给他们一个教训。计划好点。我不知道为什么。
I don't want to run. I want to punish, but I do. It's a teaching moment. All right, well, Cynthia R. asked, what was your favorite sitcom or cartoon as a kid? I had so many, I mean, I lived, I lived in the world of sitcoms, you know? I just like, wouldn't it be great to be on the castle?
我不想跑。我想惩罚，但我确实这么做了。这是一个教训时刻。好吧，那么，辛西娅·R. 问，你小时候最喜欢的情景喜剧或动画片是什么？我有太多了，我是说，我生活在，我生活在情景喜剧的世界里，你知道吗？我只是觉得，能住在那个城堡里该多好？
Wouldn't it be great to live on the love boat? Yes. Right? Or Fantasy Island. Fantasy Island, please. That ABC, they had a little run there between Happy Days, Laverne and Shirley, Tuesday nights. Forget about it. How cool to just be able to hit a jukebox
住在爱情船（The Love Boat）上该多大好？是的。对吧？或者梦幻岛（Fantasy Island）。梦幻岛，拜访一下吧。那个美国广播公司（ABC），他们在《欢乐时光》（Happy Days）、《拉维恩和雪莉》（Laverne and Shirley）之间有一段黄金时期，周二晚上。别提了。能够拍一下点唱机，
and the music, like what a fun character. How cool to have your office in the men's bathroom. Yeah, that's true, I forgot about that. All right, our last regular guy question for you, Will, is do you have a hobby? I get asked this. Do you really? And I never have an answer.
音乐就响起来，那是多么有趣的性格。把办公室设在男厕所里是多么酷的一件事。对，没错，我都忘了这茬了。好吧，维尔，我们给你的最后一个普通人问题是，你有什么爱好吗？总有人问我这个。真的吗？而我从来都答不上来。
I don't collect stamps or baseball cards or anything like that. What is, if I did have a hobby? Big finish here, big finish. I don't know if I, if I have a habitual thing. Right, yeah. That's minus, I was thinking about this. I'm like, what's my hobby? Really, like I love to go for a walk every day.
我不收集邮票、棒球卡或者诸如此类的东西。如果我真的有爱好，那会是什么呢？精彩收尾，精彩收尾。我不知道我有没有，如果我有习惯性的习惯的话。对，是的。除了这个，我一直在想这个。我想，我的爱好是什么？真的，比如我喜欢每天去散步。
And I love, I have a lot of hummingbird feeders. Okay. Because I live this sexy life. Yeah, no kidding. I do genuinely love driving my kids to school, but that's not a hobby. That's so cute. This is not a hobby because I don't do it consistently enough,
我喜欢，我有很多蜂鸟喂食器。好吧。因为我过着这种性感的生活。对，不开玩笑。我确实由衷地喜欢开车送我的孩子去学校，但这不算爱好。太可爱了。这不是爱好，因为我做得不够频繁，
but we have a chicken coop. So we have chickens. Oh. And I love it's, there's a real serenity to going out there and cleaning the chicken coop. Kind of talk to the chickens a little bit. There's a little compost section to it. I kind of make sure they have fresh, you know,
但我们有一个鸡舍。所以我们养了鸡。哦。我喜欢那种感觉，去那里清理鸡舍有一种真正的宁静感。跟鸡聊聊天什么的。里面还有一个小堆肥区。我有点确保它们有新鲜的，你知道的，
but it's not like I do that every two days. Right, right. I'll take it. I accept it. Okay, that's my hobby. It doesn't have to be it often. It's just a thing that brings you joy. Yeah.
但这并不是说我每两天就做一次。好吧，好吧。我接受了。我承认。好吧，这就是我的爱好。它不一定非得经常做。它只是一个能给你带来快乐的事物。是啊。
Tara, sorry. What are you doing? I feel like this was, don't you know one's, everyone's going to remember how bad the podcast ended. Stop it. I have a good ending. There's going to be, you're going to get so many letters.
塔拉，对不起。你在干什么？我觉得这简直是，难道你不知道大家都会记住这个播客是以多么糟糕的方式结尾的吗？别说了。我有一个很好的结局。会有，你会收到好多信的。
No, no, no. By the way, by the way, Farrell, Dud City. Steve, Steve was like. Dud City, hashtag Dud City USA. When we, when we did Steve's regular guy questions, all we did was make Steve feel like he was the most boring person on earth. He was like, oh my God.
不，不，不。顺便说一句，顺便说一句，法瑞尔（Farrell），烂透了。史蒂夫，史蒂夫就像是。烂透了之城，话题标签：美国烂透了之城。当我们，当我们问史蒂夫那些普通人问题时，我们所做的就是让史蒂夫觉得自己是地球上最无聊的人。他当时就像，哦天哪。
He was like, I am, why didn't Nancy marry me? Like, I'm hearing myself back and I've never felt worse about myself. This is why we asked to take the picture at the top. Because we like to leave people in like a shame spiral. You knew it was prophetic. We might need to change the name from regular guy quiz to just like want to feel sh**ty.
他当时就像，我是，南希为什么不嫁给我？就像，我回听自己的话，从来没有像现在这样对自我感到如此糟糕。这就是为什么我们要求在一开始就拍那张照片。因为我们喜欢把人们推进那种羞耻的漩涡里。你早就知道这是个预言。我们可能需要把“普通人问答”改名为“只想感觉像坨屎”。
Want to really feel. Now I got to get a hobby. So I can literally answer this question. We want to thank you so much for coming today, Will. And I wanted to end with this, such this sweet note from a fan from Maxi B. Maxi said this, my mom and I adore watching Will Farrell movies together and cracking up.
只想真切地感受到。现在我得去找个爱好。这样我才能直面回答这个问题。非常感谢你今天能来，维尔。我想以这个结尾，这是来自粉丝马克西·B（Maxi B）的一个非常温馨的便条。马克西写道，我和我妈妈特别喜欢一起看维尔·法瑞尔的电影，然后笑得前仰后合。
My mom just turned 70 in January. And we began talking about the thing that all kids dread talking about with their parents, the funeral arrangements. She wants cremation and a big party to celebrate her life, which I love, but she had the cutest request that she knows won't be able to happen.
我妈妈在一月份刚刚满70岁。我们开始谈论那个所有孩子都害怕跟父母谈论的话题——葬礼安排。她希望火化并举办一个盛大的派对来庆祝她的一生，我非常赞同这个想法，但她提出了一个最可爱的要求，而她知道这其实无法实现。
She asked me to please hire Will Farrell to sing her favorite song, Dust in the Wind, at her party. I just think that is the sweetest thing. And I would love for Will to know how much he means to us and our family. He has kept us going through hard times. All my love, Maxi B. Isn't that so sweet? I just think that's like you bring so much comfort
她请求我请维尔·法瑞尔在她派对上演唱她最喜欢的歌曲《风中残尘》（Dust in the Wind）。我只是觉得这太温馨了。我希望维尔能知道他对我们和我们的家庭有多么重要。他在困难时期支撑着我们度过难关。爱你的，马克西·B。这难道不是很温馨吗？我只是觉得这就好像你通过你的工作，通过你的喜剧，
to people with what you do, with your comedy, and just with who you are, you brought so much comfort to us on the office when you came in during that transition time. So, I mean, that's why we do it. That's why, I mean, that's what being an artist is. That couldn't be nicer. Nicer, and what a fun sense of humor her mom has.
以及通过你这个人本身，给人们带来了极大的安慰，你在我们过渡时期的办公室里给我们带来了那么多的安慰。所以，我的意思是，这就是我们这样做的原因。这就是，我的意思是，这就是身为艺术家的意义。这再好不过了。太美好了，她妈妈真是一个充满幽默感的人。
She wants to be cremated and wants you to sing Dust in the Wind. I love this woman, right? I know. Well, we just, we adore you, we really do. I'm just always so happy when I see you. And when we run into you, you're just one of the good guys.
她希望被火化，还想让你唱《风中残尘》。我太喜欢这个女人了，对吧？我知道。好吧，我们只是，我们太喜欢你了，真的。每次看到你我都总是那么开心。当我们偶遇你时，你总是那种真正的好人。
Oh, thanks. You're one of the good ones. Thanks, you guys. Thank you. I don't know. I'm gonna, just gonna drive in my car now. Yeah, you know what? And just let all of this praise wash over me. Own it. Okay.
哦，谢谢。你是最好的人之一。谢谢你们，伙计们。谢谢。我不知道。我，现在就要开车走了。是啊，你知道吗？就让所有的赞美向我汹涌袭来吧。接受它。好吧。
That was so much fun. So fun. Okay, before we leave for our two week break, you guys, you know how much I love birthdays. You know how much I love celebrating them. Well, we have had a wonky few weeks with scheduling. We've had a lot going on. And we were not able to celebrate Jenna's birthday
太有趣了。太有趣了。好吧，在我们离开进行为期两周的假期之前，伙计们，你们知道我有多喜欢过生日。你们知道我有多喜欢庆祝生日。好吧，我们的日程安排在过去几周里有点不太顺利。我们发生了太多事情。我们没能庆祝詹娜的生日，
when it was her birthday week. But you know what? It is never too late for birthday week. I am, honestly, I am surprised. This is so nice. Angela, you know, I spent my birthday by myself in New York city because I was shooting Mean Girls. I know.
是在她生日的那一周。但你知道吗？庆祝生日永远都不嫌迟。老实说，我很惊讶。这太棒了。安吉拉，你知道的，我在纽约市独自度过了我的生日，因为我在拍摄《贱女孩》。我知道。
And it was a little tough. I'll say my family was wonderful, Lee hid birthday presents in my suitcase for me to open. And we celebrated a little before I left, a little bit after I got home. But we have not been able to celebrate here on the pod. So ladies, sit back. I got some stuff coming your way.
那确实有点艰难。我得说我的家人太棒了，李（Lee）把生日礼物藏在我的手提箱里让我打开。我在离开前庆祝了一小会儿，回家后又庆祝了一小会儿。但我们一直没能在播客里庆祝。所以女士们，坐好吧。我有些好东西要送给你们。
Oh my gosh. Cody and Sam, I'm opening up the shower screen door thing. Cassie, I'm sad you're not here today, but we'll save some for you. Okay. I have this all hidden in the corner. I had no idea this was here. Okay.
哦天哪。科迪和萨姆，我正在打开淋浴房的推拉门。卡西，我很遗憾你今天不在这里，但我们会给你留一些的。好吧。我把这些都藏在角落里了。我根本不知道这在这里。好吧。
So first of all, this is a gift that the minute you open it, it's something you said you wanted, okay? Okay. Something I said I wanted. Oh my gosh. I really did want this. This is the lighted magnification mirror. So I can tweeze my eyebrows.
所以首先，这是一份礼物，你一打开它，就会发现它正是你之前说过你想要的东西，好吗？好吧。我说过我想要的东西。哦天哪。我真的想要这个。这是带灯光的放大化妆镜。这样我就可以修眉毛了。
And it magnifies three times the magnitude of whatever. My 49 year old eyes. Thank you so much. Wait, I have to take your picture with it. Okay. And next lady, I went to one of my favorite bakeries and I got you gluten-free brownies with sprinkles. Ooh, gluten-free dessert.
而且它可以放大三倍。我这双49岁的眼睛。非常谢谢你。等等，我得给你拍张照片。好吧。接下来的这位女士，我去了我最喜欢的一家面包店，给你买了好吃的无麸质布朗尼蛋糕，上面撒了糖针。噢，无麸质甜点。
Oh, I love it. Okay. I hope they did because it tossed around in the car. Oh, they're perfect. Thank you, lady. You're welcome. Thank you. Bye, you guys.
哦，我太喜欢了。好吧。希望它们还完好，因为在车里被颠来倒去的。哦，它们太完美了。谢谢你，亲爱的。不客气。谢谢。拜拜，伙计们。
Bye. See you in two weeks. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer.
拜拜。两周后见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利联合制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。
And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to stitropremium.com. For a free version of Ainsley Bubbicoe, go to www.stitropremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, go to code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的助理制作人是艾因斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问stitropremium.com。想要免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月，请使用优惠码：Office。本期节目暂无评论。点击转写文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。